hi my name is short net I'm a technical
consultant at Wolfram research Europe
and my talk is about Bayesian inference
in the Wolfram language so Bayesian
inference is a very powerful way for
dealing with uncertainty in your data
and for fitting models to that data and
comparing them so I hope you will enjoy
my my presentation
my name is shir Smith I'm from the
Netherlands I work in the UK for Wolfram
research Europe as a technical
consultant and a while ago I got
interested in Bayesian inference and I
started trying you know teaching myself
a bit about it read the book by a twenty
Jane's maybe some of you will know it
and because I'm a consultant I you know
people come with problems to me and I
thought well this is Bayesian inference
would be a good thing to have in my
toolbox in case someone has a problem
that could be solved in a Bayesian way
but unfortunately Mathematica doesn't
have too much in the way of that so I
decided to start my own code project on
github and write some code in particular
initially to implement what's called a
nested sampling algorithm so this
repository the link to that will be at
the end of this talk so if you're
interested and that's just a pretty
straightforward implementation of the
the nested sampling algorithm and in
this talk I want to briefly talk about
what is Bayesian inference what why is
it interesting and useful to useful to
have then I will talk about this nested
sampling algorithm and I will show you
some examples of what you can do with it
okay so very brief introduction to
Bayesian inference Bayesian inference is
based completely on conditional
probabilities so a traditional
probability is just the probability that
X is true given that you know that Y is
true and we pronounce that as the
probability of x given Y now the the
most important rule for calculating with
conditional probabilities is called a
multiplication rule and it's the
probability that x and y are true is the
probability that x is true and then
because because x is then true the
you have to multiply it by the
probability that y is true given that X
is true and this rule is always valid
it's not like the independence product
rule this is just a universal
probability law and because we can
switch X and y around on the left side
because what the end operator is
commutative you can also switch around
these two terms on the left on the right
hand side and that gives you two ways to
calculate the probability of x and y
which means that you can eliminate it
and when you do that you get Bayes rule
so Bayes rule gives you the probability
that X is true given Y in terms of the
probability that Y is true given X so it
and then there is these probabilities of
x and y that you need in order to
compensate for switching the the
conditioning around and this is very
powerful because if you are if you're
doing reasoning you'll very often
encounter situations where you have to
swap around what you know and what you
don't know so and and that's what Bayes
rule basically does it's it allows you
to swap dependencies so let's do a
really simple Bayesian inference example
we have some kind of process that
produces trues and falses we have no
idea about what what's behind this
process but we took some data and we
found that it produced three falses and
nine throughs and now we want to we have
the hypothesis that these trues and
falses are independent events so but
we're not considering Markov chain like
models where the the the next event
could be influenced by the previous so
we for the moment we're thinking okay
this might be independent and we have a
probability of P that we get a true and
one minus B that we get a false but we
don't know this parameter P so from a
Bayesian perspective P is an unknown
something that has a probability
distribution because it is unknown so
the question then is what's the
probability of this P given the fact
that we have this data and the model
because the data is the thing we have
that's right here the model is the thing
we're basically assuming for the moment
and then we by using Bayes rule we can
switch this around so we have here a
bunch of terms and each of these terms
get a name because that makes it easier
to talk about it so the first one here
so the first one here is called a
likelihood so that's the probability of
getting your data given the model and
the p value that you assumed at a
certain at a certain value then here we
have what's called prior and here we
have called what's called the evidence
now this likelihood in in this one is
probably easiest because that's what we
just learned in probability classes
while we were in school so in this case
it's just a former something we get from
a binomial distribution and Mathematica
has a built-in function called
likelihood which allows you to just
immediately get this likelihood here and
it's you know one minus B we got three
of those and we got nine through so
that's P to the power 9 and then we have
this this binomial coefficient so that's
our likelihood now then there is this
prior the prior is a mathematical way of
stating that we don't know this this
value P or at least what we believe
about what we know about this value B
not having seen the data yet that's
important so if we hadn't seen the data
then we would probably believe that the
prior is
a uniform okay you can argue with this
maybe it's not uniform there there might
be a reason why it wouldn't be uniform
but for the moment we have no reason to
believe that it has a particular value
so it could be anywhere in the interval
between 0 & 1 and then finally there is
this thing here the which is called the
evidence and the evidence you get by
basically integrating the numerator
because in the end this is has to be a
probability distribution this whole
thing has to be a probability
distribution over P this thing here
doesn't depend on P so this is just a
normalizing factor it makes it sure that
these two terms which do depend on P
become that they become a probability
distribution so the evidence is just the
integral of the likelihood times the
prior over B from 1 to 0 from 0 to 1 and
that's 1 over 13 in this case so now we
can calculate our posterior which is
what we give the name to the left hand
side and posterior we can plot together
with its probability distribution so
that's one of the nice things about
Mathematica you can when you have so
this thing here this thing here is a is
a function and then I can convert that
into into a probability distribution so
in Mathematica you can do these kind of
calculations quite quite quickly and
efficiently by using this symbolic
notation and using things like
probability distribution and then we can
plot it of course so here was our prior
so a prior is we don't know P so it
could be anywhere between 0 and 1 and
then after we've seen the data we get
this kind of bumpy probability
distribution because we've seen many
more
troost and falses obviously it skews the
p-value a bit above a half and then this
represents what we know about p-value
and once we have that that probability
distribution we can start asking
questions like what is the the mean of
this distribution so what's the expected
value of the of P or we can calculate
the mean is 5/7 apparently we can create
what's called a credible interval this
is not the same as a confidence interval
but a credible interval is basically an
interval that contains 95% of this this
posterior so this kind of gives you
error bars on where where your p-value
might be and you can ask other questions
like what's the probability that the
p-value is actually still less than 1/2
and you can see that's four point six
percent so these are the kind of things
you can do with with Bayesian inference
so is there anyone who wants to quickly
ask something before you move on okay
good yes
if you have a lot of data it tends to be
not very sensitive but prior in a
situation like this one where I felt
very little data then the prior is
actually very important like if you were
throwing and that that kind of makes
sense like if you were throwing a coin
and you were doing your best
then you're you actually have a prior
that the coin is fair that's just you
know our everyday experience tells that
this should be true so in this case this
whole model for the the whole model
would probably have a quite low prior
because there's no real reason why a
coin should have a zero B value for
example yes
yes yeah so I would say that incredible
interval is much more much more common
much more much closer to our common
sense of what we think of like a
confidence interval is usually not what
you think it is that's that's the main
problem while a credible interval is
much more intuitive I would say that's
that's it's much less easy to
misinterpret okay okay so this is a
simple example and you can see that the
symbolic tools in Mathematica make this
quite easy to do so in general if we
generalize this problem then we have
data and we have we have a model which
has some vector of unknown parameters
which I'm calling theta and the
difficulty in doing the Bayesian
analysis is usually if the evaluation of
this evidence integral integral because
the likelihood youjin you generally know
this is this you can compute using
probability theory the prior is
something you have to think about and
maybe discuss with people in order to
get at a good value because you know
there is there is quite a bit of
information in this prior but that's you
know that that's an account of model
assumption and then this integral is the
thing you have to do and in general this
this integral is quite difficult it's it
can be a very high dimensional like it's
quite easy to end up with a with a model
that has like ten parameters or
something and you can't really do this
numerically or analytically in general
so what are the ways to deal with this
problem now the a very popular way to do
it is by using what's called MCMC
methods or Markov
Monte Carlo Carlo methods I'm not going
into detail what those are exactly
because I didn't really go down that
route but the main advantage of Markov
chain Monte Carlo is that it's self
normalizing and therefore you don't need
you don't need the evidence so actually
we only need the likelihood and the
prior and that's that's great
what Markov chain Monte Carlo does is it
allows you to draw samples from the
prior from the posterior distribution so
you have the distribution you're
interested in you can draw samples from
it and if you have enough samples then
you basically have a kind of
approximation of your distribution so
instead it's like having instead of a
normal distribution you have samples
from a normal distribution and then you
use that to approximate the distribution
in the in a discrete way and that's what
MCMC does however it's the main drawback
is you're not computing the evidence and
the evidence is actually a very handy
tool for comparing different models I
will not go into detail about that too
much but if you have two competing
models that might explain the data you
need this evidence in order to assure
assess which of the two models you
should use so if you have one model and
you want to just throw that at the data
then use Markov chain Monte Carlo no
problem if you have two models or three
or four or more and you don't know what
wipe what might be a good the best one
to use you have to compute this evidence
integral and you can't do that with MCMC
or at least not just just MCMC so we
have what's called the nested sampling
algorithm the nested sampling algorithm
does allow you to estimate the evidence
and let me try and explain that to you
oh for some reason something got deleted
here somewhere when when did that happen
is that correct no I think it's best if
I just close the presentation and just
open it because I have no idea when that
happened probably a slip of the finger
somewhere no does it work
oh there yes oh good catch Thanks so the
I implemented the nested sampling
algorithm in the package I mentioned on
github and in this case I'm going to I'm
using that that package on data I draw
from a Cauchy distribution so Cauchy
distribution is notoriously very wide so
this is a it's kind of like a normal
distribution but much with much heavier
tails so the parameters it has is a
location and a scale parameter in this
case zero and one I create I generate
some test data and then I'm going to do
my nested sampling algorithm so I throw
in the likelihood function actually the
log likelihood function it's a bit
easier to work with the log which is the
Cauchy distribution of to the two
parameters which I'm estimating so they
slot in as as a function and the data
now my prior I specify in a general way
so I say that the first argument is a
location parameter the second argument
is a scale parameter and that
automatically gives me in this code the
proper priors to use for that for those
parameters and then I say well I want to
look and investigate my location
parameter between minus 10 and 10 and my
scale parameter from 1 1 over 100 205
and I believe that the true values are
in there somewhere in that in that range
so these are some options it's not
important right now
these are where the data that I drew
drew so you can see the 10 samples one
of them is a huge outlier which is
something that's not uncommon folks Cosi
distributions and then here is my result
which I present as a data set
and the nested sampling algorithm also
created a bunch of points in in the the
parameter play space so this is a point
that has a location parameter of 0.77
and a scale parameter of 0.4 it gives it
tells me how likely that point is as a
prior it gives me the lot likelihood and
it gives me weights and these weights
are what allows you to calculate the
evidence basically so what this
algorithm does so let me give you a
little plot of the problem we have so
this is the the log likelihood function
that I threw in here so the likelihood
of getting the data from the from that
distribution for different location and
scale parameters and you can see that
the likelihood is the highest somewhere
around here now what the nested sampling
algorithm does is it some samples the
prior it generates a bunch of samples
from the prior and then you keep the
best ones alive so the best ones in this
case the best ten I mark in red these
have the highest likelihood out of the
ones that I have right now the brown one
of the the gray ones are not yet in in
this iteration so I can I can skip I had
food truly algorithm as I ran it and
then here there is the worst one the
11th one and this kind of gives me a
likelihood boundary which and I won't
accept any new points that are worse
than this one so when I now move up
through the animation it's a little bit
fast okay so every time I generate a new
point so this one for example and now
this one has become the worst and every
time I generate a new point I draw from
the prior
but I make sure it's better than this
one so it's it's within this within this
area and that's what allows me to do the
the evidence integral because we're in
normal integration you're kind of
cutting up your integration domain in
slices and then you dice it up and that
won't work in high dimensions what this
algorithm does instead is it estimates
the area of these kind of onion layers
so each of these contours is kind of
like a light like a like an onion she
peel let's stick with the cooking
analogies and you can estimate the the
area of this thing and because you know
the likelihood on on this or on this
peel you can do you can estimate the
that particular contribution to the
integral and that's how you do the
evidence integral
that's according to likelihood so the
ones with the highest likelihood are the
best no now they this is just for
calculating for calculating the evidence
and what you can now actually do is that
you each of these points you assign a
weight and you then you get samples from
your posterior distribution so in a
normal market in Monte Carlo you just
generate a bunch of samples and those
are all weighted the same they all have
the same weight well in nested sampling
you generate weighted points and these
represent your posterior distribution
and we can now also plot this posterior
distribution so these are the samples
and then the size of these bubbles is
the weights these this points got and I
can use some mathematical functions to
create instead a kind of density plot so
this is actually now my my posterior my
posterior function so I can actually
visualize it I can also look at things
like what's the covariance between my
between my parameters so for example the
location and the scale parameter have a
little bit of covariance in what you can
see here it's it's a little bit you know
it's it's not entirely straight and then
define one of the last things that's
quite interesting to do is that you
generate the predictive distribution so
I could if I were to draw in the next
sample from my data the eleventh one
then I would like to have a probability
distribution
for that and you can get a probability
distribution by using for example
maximum likelihood estimation if you do
that you get a also almost out of time
but it's fine you can you get one
location a scale parameter and you just
use that as the the distribution what
you hear what I'm here doing in this
blue function this posterior predictive
function is that I actually have a lot
of Cauchy distributions with different
parameters and they're all weighted
according to how likely they are and
that's how I construct a new probability
distribution that tells me where my next
sample is going to be so that's that's
um that's something you can do and
actually because Mathematica has quite a
lot of ways to generate these
distributions so for example I used in
this data set come on I have here a data
distribution which is just in generated
from empirical distribution so you can
just throw in the points and then you
have a power you have a posterior and
you can calculate it you can calculate
with it it's just like in an any other
distribution you have in Mathematica and
finally just as a kind of let's see
where is where from my repository so as
I promised I have a github repository
where you can just get the get the code
and install it and mess around with it
for yourself yes yeah that's the talk
let's do some questions
you